e voi non mi stai polsi
per gli a tutti ragazzi e poi venuti a
questo video sono felice che oggi siamo
su ogni man frostbite desidera guardato
se vuoi guardare la mia trasmissione zio
ti droghi non ti faceva da che molto si
molto simile a phinet freddy's e medium
in realtà è un gioco che si svolge nella
propria stanza nella propria camera che
questa qui coi muri con le stelline
manco ci avessi tre anni ed è proprio
per questo che sono in pigiama perché ho
preferito fare questo video in pigiama
proprio come se fossi nel gioco quindi
in questo mese sono in cosplay in questo
momento sono i cosplay the boogie man a
quattro modi per entrare nella stanza
tramite la porta che è una porta che
necessita di olio poi la finestra
l'armadio angoscie tino anche
sull'armadio di olio è il sistema di
ventilazione credo che sia questo che
sembra che siano squartando un
transformers però io praticamente devo
cercare le batterie per la torcia e poi
la torcia allo spavento che è perfetto
si coricava anche chi cazzo dorme così
no vabbè ma cos'è ma cosa si va beh ma
anch'io questi pupazzi del cazzo mi fa
piacere che avendo in casa mia girino
queste belle persone fantastico infatti
a vedere dove sono io a questo armadio a
perché giustamente il sistema di
ventilazione collega l'armadio ovvio c'è
ci mancherebbe altro
rick wright mais battenti cos'era a una
abiti faceva solo cagare un pò in mano
non serviva un cast perfetto era una
parte inutile bene ai ragazzi benissimo
invece il sacco da solo d'oro vinto il
mouse qui su spinto a letto avevo
veramente letto su scritto mi del mouse
a zoomare zoomafie che non pensate male
sporca giovani e quindi questa è la
torcia questa mia nonna che russa sia
così guarda sotto il letto perfetto per
pagare perché eletto grazie era passata
a miope di la giornata passata a lui
grazie 0 devo guardarmi in giro che bel
poster devo ammazzano e si scarica la
batteria in un secondo è finita il caso
su di pile sono le duracell made in
china diventato tutto più buio casa ma
tu non sei zac efron no e non è andato
via perfetto quindi arriva lo devo
sentire quando lo sento mi gestazione
la ragazza è orribile stanotte non dormo
più mi armo di pile qualcuno datevi
delle batterie vi prego sì grazie grazie
pupazzo grazie ti farò [ __ ] la
barbie come promesso 20 secondi ragazzi
raga soli ancora una volta l'uccello ci
ha salvato il culo che bella frase che
ho appena detto
la prima è andata abbastanza bene
tranquillo seriamente cesso bambini ma è
un bambino
deduco risi dalle coperte e dalla foto
della madre cioè una bella mills
comunque e commercia sei stato tu sì
stato visto ma non sento più se mi
arrivano ce vado vado al culo
sembra un po la mia prof di matematica
con la vecchia parte il condotto che chi
è messo male un merda merda merda merda
farà vivo come come la torcia data
[ __ ] quindi se mi spunta ancora una
volta sono morto grazie frate perché
prima mi deve aprire poi deve entrare ok
quindi lo fa in due pezzi si sa fa
parkour è mancato il respiro per un
secondo fantastico e grazie torni a
trovarci anzi non ha staccato il piace è
presa ma le braccia o bene dov'è il
mouse ragazzini regalato ma usa natale
l'ho perso ai quattro dietro il monitor
arkema alla fine ha dovuto farmela
l'imboscata nel letto se non era
contento c'è ma lo sentivo io che aveva
bisogno di ci siamo ragazzi ho fatto
difficoltà massima proprio il top della
difficoltà serie non so se riesco e per
carità approcci pro ragazzi cos'è sto
rumore
6 fa centro trovando il preservativo
pregava per tre chi è lou reed i maniaci
chi è fatemi saperti con mark io io io
lo sapevo io sapevo che c'era sotto sta
minkia anche io ho perso e perdendo
aumentato la difficoltà un genio per un
numero un [ __ ] genio regate per caso
hai preso affitto sul mio albero a baci
subito subito fuori dai [ __ ] 26
cagato addosso ma chi ha imprecato la
radio
ma dove da doha dove cosma così è
successo non ha anche visto tocca a
carissimo già non ho fatto niente solo
porto ragazze non so come ma sono morto
all'inizio non pensavo ci fosse già
subito scusatemi ma ma una tisana grazie
anzi due fanno due mtc del sedativo
quello per i cavalli con i ragazzi è
fatto strabene per essere tipo phinet
freddy's però con più mostri ainhoa
mettici anche canzone sua barbara d'urso
che va bene così non mi sono
assolutamente lamentato ma come cazzo ho
fatto completamente a caso sono riuscito
a evitarlo a carissimo una possibilità
su un milione di azzeccare sta cosa a
zero il tempismo di favi j
come mai nei videogiochi horror un
minuto dura un secondo e quando siamo a
scuola un minuto dura un ora come cazzo
è possibile same same summers fare
e sa perché
a chiederlo ragazzi prova l'ultima notte
poi direi che basta se riesco a fare
questa record assoluto
stando alla rinchiusa stava uscendo ma
siccome loro illuminato e rientrato e
l'ha chiusa fantastico che silent hill
ragazzi siamo in silent hill nostra
mischia succede a madonna ogni volta che
vado avanti nelle notti succede qualcosa
ma sei tu che stai scoraggiando che fai
st stanno bene ma vedo che hai fatto una
fan artea gli one direction ma che figo
quello lì è harry styles miglia come si
riconosce bene ok dai pupazzo schifoso
lancia mina batteria ma che te ne fai a
parte che il fatto che non so se vai a
pile ma sicuramente se vai a pile
significa che tale di in fila quindi
vedi tiratele fuori dal culetto tuo
vengo lì e ti squarto io mi trovo
tirchio come la morte quei cinque
dollari sospeso al supermarket quando ti
ho comprato l'avevo detto la mamma che
devo comprarci la bamba con quei cinque
dollari nostro pupazzo de merda che aver
gesù hanno il sole è sorto il sole
all'improvviso fantastico parlare
ragazzuoli è stata abbastanza carino è
stato difficile aggiustata la lampada ci
sta a babbo natale
mi fate fissare la fia voglio solo
vedere come muore ai ragazzi solo per
curiosità
sei più bello di quanto pensassi
personalmente penso che sia figo
abbastanza quasi quanto find and the
freddo ovviamente non lo batte nessuno
fa niente 13 quindi ragazzi vi auguro
buona nota a tutti e non abbiate paura
perché ricordatevi che a schiacciare i
nostri ci pensa lo zio fa sempre che
qualcuno si tolga le batterie dal culo
però quello è un altro discorso quindi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto come
se la vita è piaciuta se documento è un
mi piace anche a passioni facebook e
camerini adottata per schizzare a
doversi discreta non ci vediamo il
prossimo vivo